airline executives are in washington
pleading with the white house and
congress to extend coronavirus relief
airline employees are hoping to avoid
mass job cuts
if government funding is allowed to run
out this month
chris vancleave is at washington's
reagan national airport chris what is
at stake for this really battered
industry
well good morning this is a case where
trouble on the tarmac is likely to be
felt well beyond the terminal commercial
aviation supports more than
10 million u.s jobs that works out to
about one out of every 14 jobs in this
country so massive layoffs here
could ripple through the larger economy
that's why you're seeing
bipartisan support to act even if that
action remains stuck in a legislative
holding pattern
[Applause]
in 12 days these flight attendants
rallying on capitol hill
will be out of work furloughed unless
congress extends its 25
billion dollar airline payroll support
program
real people who need to feed our
families
people like flight attendant arnold
ramirez seen in this stunning photo
capturing the moment he learned he was
losing his dream job
in the stomach the arizona native is
among the 19
000 at american airlines alone who will
be laid off or furloughed in october he
thought he had a backup plan working
retail
but just learned that store is closing
so he'll lose that job too
i just feel like everything is just
getting taken away from me i just
hope it gets better soon because i i
really would love to keep my job
i i just i have not
have no words for that passenger traffic
remains down 65 percent
u.s carriers lost 11 billion dollars in
the second quarter
alone as many as 76 thousand airline
workers could be furloughed next month
and service to cities nationwide slashed
monica colb is a widowed mother of two
who became a flight attendant after her
husband died of cancer six years ago i
was setting myself for
a new way i guess a blank canvas
to paint my own my story again you know
as a single mom
trying to find that happiness that i
thought i had lost last year she beat
breast cancer
now she's at risk of losing her family's
livelihood and health insurance
is this scarier than battling cancer
it's as scary as this might be i still
have hope
i've beaten cancer and i'm here i didn't
get over this to be
brought down by a virus
critics argue airlines were already
given taxpayer money
and point out that they're bracing for
the potential of a four-year recovery so
it's unclear if a six-month extension
would actually
save any jobs in the long run for flyers
if there's not an extension
prepare for fewer options and longer
travel times as the airlines
will start reducing service particularly
in smaller and medium cities
anthony so many folks in the airline
industry in desperate situations chris
thank you